said Claude Rains in Casablanca says to
tip Bogart he says what MIT what brought
you to Casablanca and Bogart says the
waters and and Claude Rains says it's a
desert and Booker says something like I
was mistaken I was misinformed I was
missing which is great dialogue just
great dialogue music it's music you know
which is the difference between speak
like we're doing here and an interesting
dialogue and interesting dialogue but
you said earlier that when you're right
you're sorry you said earlier when your
wife reads your first draft or second
draft that you know she's an actress so
in you're essentially writing for actors
how does a writer write for what they
think people will say versus what actors
oh just years of practice and listening
to readings I find readings incredibly
valuable workshopping
and films and TV should be done the same
way actors are not shy about telling you
what doesn't work for them just like
singers are not shy about telling a
songwriter hey you know when I land on
that it doesn't go the words don't go
with the notes sort of a simple answer
to your question though is read your
dialog aloud yes very good point and I
don't looking you can start using a
world that that's not coming off my
tongue very easily I don't think I want
to ask somebody to say that you know
when composers compose and you're
writing for an orchestra and you don't
know how to play the French horn and you
can't play the oboe and quite often
after it's done you have people play
through the parts and they say that's
unplayable you can't finger it that way
and they have to go back and they have
to change their parts because they're
not writing for that instrument you know
they think about drama in any form is
what actions are playable what and
they're not playable so what I've
learned in the course of my writing life
and of watching other people's work is
is
crying the woman cries that's not a play
you don't be more descriptive about it
what is she doing when she's crying that
the actors always gonna find something
else to do something better but you got
to give them a hint you know actors hate
two things more than anything one to be
told how to say a line and two blocking
because blocking is the it's blocking is
like structure it's the easiest thing in
the world to do if all you do as a
director is block you're not much of a
director actors like directors who like
I'm sure that's why they love Tom as a
director because he's also been an actor
and so he knows how actors think you
know and so what I what but I think it's
really just experience in writing a lot
and and really get allowed and and
getting other people to read it one
there are tricks that you can use in
stage dialogue one is people don't
typically talk people typically don't
you know in real life people don't say
you may not go there you cannot go you
can right away hear that that sounds but
you know if you think about it
if you're sitting in a room with an
actor they're noticing things about
people you are not noticing and they're
looking for mannerisms they're looking
for expressions what are they doing with
their hands is everything coming out
monotone or is the pitch going up or is
it going down does it go faster does it
go slow they're listening for all these
things in the same what differentiates
this Texan from this New Yorker and how
are they sounding so different and why
is this story working and this one is
and why am i captivated and listening
this person why is this person sound
shallow so if they ever have to sound
shallow then they know well if I'm kind
of looking to the side like this and I
kind of talk out inside of my mouth and
on what words would I be saying then
they noticing and good dialogue writers
also have really good ears and they're
listening for the way people speak and
and they remember those sorts of things
I'm a big believer in riedel writers
rivals who is that like a character that
got caught out of fiddler
what is that I'm a big believer in in
writers notebooks I've been keeping them
since I was very young and I don't mean
Diaries I don't mean today I went to
Peter desper house and he made fun of me
all day and was the same thing every
time you come say I don't need to write
that down because I'm gonna remember it
but I mean like not sometimes I'll go
months without putting anything in but
Lydia Davis who's a wonderful writer
said that what she likes about keeping
in a book and I think this is really
valuable advice is is you're never
really starting with a blank page
because you know is go to the notebook
and find something you wrote and play
with it and and if you're blocked on one
thing you go over there and you you work
you work on that and maybe it doesn't go
anywhere but maybe it does and that's
another thing that writers have a hard
time coming to terms with that is sort
of another corollary to the figure is I
want to use that word a lot before I
forget it so you know I was just gonna
say that you have to get used to things
going into a corner and maybe you have
to leave it alone and go to something
else this goes back to what Peter was
saying about the guy that was working on
one script for 10 years that's crazy
because and
even if it wasn't a script that's crazy
you want to work on different things
because different days may call you to
something and you're not gonna get
anything done if you just work on one
thing but but this goes back again to
also to the idea of observation that
people people think for example that
objectivity in the world exists but it
doesn't if if three people walk into
this room would they all see the same
thing it's he chairs rug desk know if an
interior designer was to walk in this
room they would get nauseous if a
carpenter came in they'd be looking at
the shelves plumb if a psychologist came
in they'd be looking at the titles of
the books and if a chiropractor came in
they'd be looking at our posture and
saying I see money coming my way
slouching but
the the eye doesn't tell the brain what
it sees the brain tells the eyes what to
look for and so the I didn't know that
and so actors are constantly looking at
when they're seeing any extreme and
behavior they're paying attention to the
littlest things you know it's not just
that his voice raises but what's he
doing with his hands while he's doing it
how is this posture changed it's gonna
use that and so again the same thing
good writers when they hear people talk
they're saying did that person get
tongue-tied when she got really angry or
did this whole slew of stuff just come
rolling off the tongue and does this
sound like something she said a lot of
times or is this something that you know
is she saying it legato or staccato you
know it's like I'm so angry you I could
just bust or is it I'm so angry at you
alright cook just bust and you all these
things they're listening for these
things saying wow listen how the
emotions coming out in everyday people
doing stuff that's the way I want to
write the dialogue so it's you look at
what you're interested in and if you're
a good dialogue writer you don't just
think of what words they're gonna say
it's what have I seen people do when
they're trying to demonstrate them when
they're demonstrating that emotion how
do the words come out we saw an
interesting interaction of somebody
steal someone's parking space and the
guy handled it pretty well he was
waiting patiently but he said something
to the woman but the woman was like you
know didn't give him the bird but she
basically told him where to go
then she turned around so just watching
that whole interaction was fascinating I
mean I it was like a TV show I couldn't
believe that she was a real character
but but again a great writer would have
listened to every word and how they got
strung together and how did how did she
express what words did she did she use
she said sorry you were too late but
again cut him off and then said he was
too late pretty much yeah yeah and again
I think in New York but the whole idea
of the bar
language when she said sorry you're just
too late was it you sorry
you're just too late now or was it sorry
you were just too late yeah but I mean
all of those things matter right subtext
and and so again it's if you're
interested in that I mean a lot of
writers don't realize you know they're
so interested in story and you know how
whatever I doing that you know in act 2
to end it instead of thinking of how
would this person express themselves in
this situation to make me feel that I'm
part of this scene so that I could put
myself in their place and feel what
they're doing through the words I would
just add that that that is what drafting
is for because in one draft you're gonna
be focused on the story and then maybe
when you've got the story you're gonna
look at word choice and another draft
and then you're gonna look at the
dialogue and you know really polish the
dialogue this is why you have to
disabuse young writers of the notion
that three drafts from their dunno what
draft do you want in your novel now oh
my god
no but it's I encourage that we're
waiting that's why I you know again if
you took 10 years to write a novel I
totally get that right because novels
are the heart that's so hard they don't
have a long age Donna Tartt who's an
amazing writer shreds one novel she
publishes a novel every 10 years and but
she's working her you know five hundred
pages and there's a lot and that's how
long your novel is 500 and I'm cutting a
lot but the thing is you again he has an
advantage because he's willing to put it
down it's not painful for him to put bad
things on paper which makes him really
unlikable in my opinion well that's not
the only reason no but I was just
warning polite when dimension of my
unlike ability
you